hey 42 here fresh cranberries can be
bounced like a rubber ball welcome to
RIF Luna mops have no mouths they live
off the energy they stored when they
were caterpillars our study found that
women look their oldest at 3:30 p.m.
every Wednesday
this is because this is when women are
typically under the most stress at work
and have the lowest energy levels when
the moon is directly overhead you weigh
slightly less at Birth a polar bear can
weigh as little as five hundred groans
so small that you can hold it in one of
your hands but at maturity polar bears
can reach up to 500 kilograms who owns
space no one the outer space treaty
signed by all major spacefaring nations
prohibit claiming territory in space or
on celestial bodies space is considered
the shared heritage of mankind you can
actually start a fire with ice in the US
if you find a bald eagle feather on the
ground you need a permit to pick it up
the Sun evaporates about a trillion tons
of water a day whenever a pregnant woman
suffers from organ damage like after a
heart attack the fetus sends stem cells
to the organ helping it to repair the
ashes of one in 50 people who are
cremated are never collected by
relatives Disney Parks developed a pink
color that's meant to help things
visually disappear by tricking the eye
into ignoring it they named it go away
Green a blunt natural blue-green color
use on unsightly park structures like
fences garbage bins and admin buildings
to help them blend in with the landscape
women can get pregnant whilst they're
already pregnant this rare phenomenon is
called super fat asian and attosecond
is one billion of a billion of a second
dogs and elephants are the only animals
that understand printing France is no
longer the world biggest wine producer
Italy has overtaken it thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2
you